tomorrow joe biden will give his much
anticipated state of the union address
already a presidency in crisis putin's
aggressive land grab in eastern europe
already rocking the stock market and
energy markets
this is going to put even more pressure
on joe biden to deliver for the american
people so
what can we expect in this pivotal
speech for that we bring in the co-host
of america's newsroom and co-host of the
five
dana perino hi dana perino tonight's
going to be humongous everyone is going
to be watching what do you anticipate
him doing with this ukraine crisis and
how does he insert that into the state
of the union which was already
a higher wire for this guy
well i missed you today on the five so
i'm glad i get to be on your great show
it's been so informative tonight um so
here's the thing so president biden got
news today that the abc poll has him at
37 approval that is what he is looking
at so it's not just that americans have
an opinion about him but they have
formed a judgment and so he as you say
it was a very high bar for him to clear
anyway i expect that you will see some
grace notes some attempts at unity and
he'll be able to introduce again to
america his supreme court nominee
katanji brown jackson who had a pretty
good rollout the other day now that said
just imagine you and your sister jesse
played monopoly a whole weekend and you
got all the pieces out on the board and
everything's going very well and then
your neighbor kid comes over and kicks
the board over that's basically what
vladimir putin did to the state of the
union speech these speeches usually take
several months to put together because
you're talking about
one you want to say what are my
accomplishments and two where are we
going i think on those two fronts it's
very difficult there in my opinion are
three elephants in the room one is
inflation and that leads to energy
policy and we've seen what it's like to
have a european
nations have to deal with the fact that
their energy policy has made them so
weak in the eyes of vladimir putin that
now they're having to take drastic
action historic action to try to right
that wrong
biden is going to have to deal with the
fact that people are paying so much more
at the pump and at the grocery store and
for everything else that's number one
number two i mentioned accomplishments
aside from the infrastructure bill i
don't know what else he can talk about
where people are going to rise up and
have a lot of applause he can't really
talk about buildback better i doubt that
you hear that phrase tomorrow night the
third thing is jesse about a month ago
on the five i said the administration
should not wait until the state of the
union address to announce that these
mass mandates are over they did wait
those have been announced over the last
couple of days in all of these blue
states and now by the federal government
and
it is so nakedly transparent that it was
political that it wasn't backed by
science and believe me i don't think the
cove and moms of 2022 are going to
forget it if only he had listened to
dana perrina we've done we say that
every day telling him and telling him to
watch the fight thank you so much dan
i'll see you tomorrow okay bye-bye hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else